when i was younger i really really
really valued freedom freedom was one of
my core core values
and ironically it still is it's probably
one of my top three values but
it's a different definition of freedom
my old definition was freedom to freedom
to do anything i want freedom to do
whatever i feel like whenever i feel
like
and now i would say that the freedom
that i'm looking for is internal freedom
so it's freedom from it's freedom from
reaction it's freedom from feeling angry
it's freedom from being sad it's freedom
from
being forced to do things but i'm
looking for freedom from internally and
externally whereas before i was looking
for freedom too